menschen müssen mit der künstlichen
intelligenz ki verschmelzen denn nur so
können wir einer drohenden apokalypse
durch eine super ki entgehen diese angst
treibt tesla und space ex-chef ihnen
mast dazu menschen mit maschinen zu
verbinden und somit eine symbiose
zwischen uns und der ki herzustellen
noch in diesem jahr sollen die ersten
gehirn chip tests mit menschen starten
doch es gibt kritik und sogar angst und
das in der wissenschaft klicks von
science and future los geht's herzlich
willkommen für allen masc ist klar wir
menschen sind zitat zu dumm um
künstliche intelligenz zu schlagen und
deswegen haben wir seiner ansicht nach
nur eine einzige chance mitmachen
in einem podcast mit dem us youtuber joe
hogan hat den mast jetzt über die pläne
seines stabs neuerer linke plaudert die
forschung des unternehmens hält er für
unabdingbar um zu verhindern dass die
menschheit von künstlicher intelligenz
abgehängt wird er befürchtet ansonsten
eine drohende apokalypse verursacht
durch die übermacht der künstlichen
intelligenz werden ja schon darüber
berichtet
er fürchtet letztlich das matrix
szenario und es beginnt mit
marodierenden robotern die jeden
umbringen bei matrix haben ja ihre
potter die weltherrschaft übernommen
die menschen existieren zwar noch aber
sie leben in einer künstlichen welt die
ihnen über ein implantat eben ähnlich zu
neuerer link ins gehirn projiziert wird
dabei sind sie nur noch material für die
ki roboter sie haben die macht
übernommen
diese angst treibt ihn und sein
unternehmen neuling kann erinnert immer
wieder daran dass im laufe der evolution
die weniger intelligenten spezies durch
die intelligenteren verdrängt worden
sind seine technologie zit also primär
gar nicht auf menschen mit schweren
hirnschäden ab wie es das momentane
ziehen von eurer link noch ist dennoch
steht fest patientinnen und patienten
mit gedächtnisproblemen oder einem
hirnschlag könnten mit hilfe von einem
gehirn computer interface wie es
neuerlich implantieren will ihr gehirn
wie der effektiver nutzen dazu sagt der
unternehmer in der aktuellen podcast
folge im prinzip kann es alles
reparieren was im gehirn falsch läuft
menschen mit motorischen störungen
könnten
durch das implantat also kontrolle über
bestimmte körperfunktionen
zurückbekommen das ist in mas
vorstellung allerdings nur der
nebenschauplatz wie gesagt es geht im
unternehmer vielmehr um die rettung der
gesamten menschheit seiner vision
zufolge könnten wir schon in einigen
wenigen jahren elektronische geräte
direkt mit unserem gehirn verbinden und
zwar mit hilfe implantierter chips im
gehirn die bits und bytes in gedanken
über setzen können und umgekehrt und
ihnen maske ist mehr als optimistisch im
aktuellen podcast berichtet er dass
möglicherweise bereits zitat innerhalb
eines jahres eine vision des gehirn
implantats fertig sei das auch für
menschen geeignet ist dank des gehirn
computer interfaces könnten wir alle
sagen nicht nur viel schneller mit
anderen menschen sondern auch mit
anderen computern interagieren und das
quasi per elektronischer
gedankenübertragung bis zum echten ki
menschen könnte es allerdings noch 25
jahre dauern
und dazu gibt es aber konkrete pläne der
reihe nach bereits bis zum kommenden
jahr 2021 soll das hirn computer
implantat auf den markt gebracht werden
an diesem kleinen wenige mast weiterhin
festhalten denn schon jetzt seien wir
menschen in gewisser weise cyborg wesen
dazu in den masken podcast wenn man sein
smartphone nicht hat fühlt sich das wie
eine fehlende gliedmaßen im vergangenen
jahr 2009 10 hatte das unternehmen
bereits verkündet dass das implantat an
einem affen getestet wurde und zwar mit
erfolg das tier ist demnach in der lage
gewesen mit seinem gehirn einen computer
zu steuern und vor kurzem
veröffentlichte maske eine studie auf
einem treffer in der es hieß dass
bereits 3000 elektroden mit einem
operation roboter in das gehirn von
ratten eingesetzt worden sind
der ursprüngliche plan nämlich bereits
ende 2009 10 einen menschen das erste
implantat einzupflanzen
gegen allerdings nicht auf das kennt man
ja von maske und seinen vorhersagen
doch dieses jahr soll es dann endlich
soweit sein und die methode dafür sollte
zitat super sicher und einfach zu
benutzen sein dann müssten nutzen und
risiken abgewogen werden
konkret soll ein sensor ins menschliche
gehirn implantiert werden der nur wenige
millimeter groß ist über fäden ist
dieser mit elektroden verbunden die dann
wiederum die nervenzellen konnte
der sensor wird über bluetooth gesteuert
sein empfänger wird hinter dem ohr
befestigt und über eine app die auf dem
smartphone läuft gesteuert die
elektroden simulieren nicht nur die
nervenzellen durch elektrische impulse
sondern messen auch die aktivität der
neuronen die rede ist vom flexiblen
fäden die dünner sein sollen als
menschliche haare somit würde das
verletzungsrisiko für das menschliche
gehirn im vergleich zu anderen mensch
maschine schnittstellen enorm gesenkt
zudem seien diese neuen entwicklung auch
in der lage deutlich mehr daten zu
transportieren doch wie soll das alles
funktionieren schließlich ist das
menschliche gehirn super komplex doch im
grunde funktioniert es ähnlich wie ein
computer nämlich mit hilfe von einsen
und nullen also den binärcode eine eins
steht für die aktion einer nervenzelle
die null steht für ruhezustand doch der
große unterschied zu computern
nervenzellen verändern sich permanent
sie ordnen sich für kurze zeit oder
lange zeit an
so können wir uns immer mehr wissen ein
prägendes aber auch wieder vergessen
oder verändern
durch das so genannte machine learning
kann auch ein computer dazu lernen aber
wenn er dinge einmal kann oder weiß gibt
es keine möglichkeit dieses abzustufen
oder abzuschwächen nur zu löschen genau
diese lücke könnte neuerer link mit
elektroden direkt im menschlichen gehirn
füllen so entsteht eine computer
schnittstelle so werden wir menschen
also in der lage sein direkt mit unserem
bewusstsein in computersysteme zu gehen
laut musk während es in solch einem fall
unsere kolleginnen und kollegen unsere
nachbarinnen und nachbarn oder aber
unsere verwandtschaft mass große
hoffnung dabei wir menschen teilen uns
unseren lebensraum mit der ki und so hat
sie keinen grund uns gefährlich zu
werden nur wenn der mensch mit maschinen
verschmilzt und dadurch klüger schneller
und produktiver wird werden wir mass
vorstellungen zufolge nicht von einer
potenziell zerstörerischen supercup
gehängt das alles würde unsere welt
komplett auf den kopf stellen anstatt
eine e mail zu tippen würden wir sie
denken der computer verwandelt unsere
gedanken dann in den entsprechenden text
der versendet werden kann und man ahnt
es schon dass es nur eine zwischenstufe
mit solch einem gehirn interface könnten
menschen aber eben nicht nur schneller
mit computern sondern eben auch mit
anderen menschen mit anderen neue rolle
interagieren per elektronischer
gedankenübertragung langfristig müssten
dafür nervenzell bereiche aktiviert und
ihre signal interpretiert werden und das
im großen stil für die masse eben eine
art hirn cloud also in der die gehirne
der menschen vernetzt werden alle
gedanken wären dann für alle verfügbar
die an diese hirn cloud angeschlossen
werden somit hätten wir also zugriff auf
die gedanken und erfahrungen anderer
menschen absolut crazy aber auch absolut
spooky auch wenn wir bestimmtes
fachwissen haben wollen müssen wir nur
an diesen wunschdenken und könnten schon
die gedanken entsprechender fachleute
herunterladen klar ist die kommunikation
verläuft da direkt zwischen gehirn und
gehirn ohne datenverlust oder
verzögerung wieder unser mund noch
unsere sprache wären dann mehr notwendig
um komplexe inhalte an andere zu
vermitteln doch es sind noch viele
fragen offen wird die technik jemals
zuverlässig funktionieren und was sagen
die gemessenen elektrischen signale
überhaupt aus klingt alles nach
science-fiction pur und zahlreiche
fachleute zweifeln auch noch an der
umsetzbarkeit dieser vision denn ein
riesiges problem bleibt die
speicherkapazität der computersysteme
denn selbst supercomputer sind derzeit
lediglich in der lage
wenige sekunden der aktivität des
menschlichen gehirns aufzuzeichnen
dennoch zeigen einzelne fälle auf was
bereits heute möglich ist
querschnittsgelähmte die roboterarme nun
mit hilfe ihrer gedanken steuern
länger schon gibt es auge und ohr
implantiert die blinden und gehörlosen
das sehen bzw das hören ermöglichen doch
wird die technologie diesen riesigen
hype um neuling wirklich gerecht
fachleute auf diesem gebiet sind
unterschiedlicher meinung der
neurowissenschaftler david zu ziehen
hatte nach einer neuen präsentation im
vergangenen sommer geurteilt dass
neuerdings gut für den kurzfristigen
medizinischen einsatz aufgestellt sei
ebenso wie für die nächsten schritte in
der forschung der us biomedizintechnik
ludwig hatte dagegen gehalten dass
neuling keineswegs neue ansätze für
grundlegende probleme gestalte
in der industrie sei einiges davon schon
längst bekannt fest steht jedenfalls
innenmaß und das neue rating team
träumen groß und schaffen grundlagen für
neue technologien
so nähern wir uns immer weiter einer der
drei versionen des sogenannten transform
an ismus an der die
digitale neue mensch auch als upload
bezeichnet diese vision ist ziemlich
radikal
denn demnach wird das bewusstsein des
menschen durch eine vollständige
digitalisierung transformiert der name
dieses prozesses hole brain emulation
oder auch ab loading das gehirn wird
hier also quasi als austauschbare
hardware definiert mensch und maschine
haben sich dann so angenähert dass eine
digitale kopie von personen möglich ist
ebenso wie ein download der identität
unsere jeweilige gehirn software kann
auf avatar überspielt werden
doch selbst im musk zufolge ist ein
digitaler gehirn ersatz noch weit weg
etwa 25 jahre könnte es möglicherweise
noch dauert bis ein interface entwickelt
wird bei dem alle neuronen mit einer
erweiterung verknüpft werden dazu ihnen
musk dann wäre mehr von einem selbst in
der cloud statt im eigenen körper und im
unterschied zu matrix werden wir dann
nicht von der ki plus sklaven gemacht
weil wir eben teil ihrer welt sind und
so eben nicht gefahr laufen von ihnen
versklavt zu werden sondern mit ihnen
kooperieren und sie nutzen wir sind dann
die identitäten in der digitalen welt
und die ja so muss man es sagen die
bewusstseins dort sie würden dann keine
eigenen identitäten bilden also die ki
sondern die würde zum teil von uns
werden und so den rohbau das eröffnet
wirklich unglaubliche perspektiven unter
gefahren oder das ende unserer spezies
ehrlich gesagt ist das überhaupt nicht
klar
die philosophin und
kognitionswissenschaften susanne
schneiders direktorin des instituts mind
and society ims an der university of
connecticut findet die idee von eurer
link bedenklich in einem beitrag für den
fenchel times und die new york times
waren sie dass der versuch das
menschliche gehirn mit künstlicher
intelligenz zu verbinden in einem
geistigen selbstmord enden könnte sie
warnt davor dass dann informationen die
computer bereitstellen das bewusstsein
ersetzen sprich nur eigene erfahrung
kann bewusstsein erzeugen einen computer
nur informationen wenn diese
informationen dann ins gehirn gelangen
ersetzen sie das bewusstsein
denn das speist sich laut schneider aus
erfahrung ihre these
wir sterben dann geistig sprich sie
befürchtet und hat sogar angst davor
dass die matrix über neuling direkt ins
gehirn kommt macht also das auslöst die
matrix was er eigentlich verhindern will
das würde allerdings bedeuten dass unser
gehirn unser bewusstsein unsere
persönlichkeit ist und das ist alles
andere als erwiesen transplantierte zum
beispiel berichten immer wieder dass sie
neue wesenszüge haben und die
us-amerikanerin kers silvia besuchte
nach einer herz und
lungentransplantation sogar die eltern
des spenders und musste feststellen dass
sie ganz konkret wesenszüge von ihm
übernommen hatte über das herz und die
lunge wir sehen also wie wenig wir
darüber wissen wer wir sind und wo wir
uns in unserem körper befinden und ob
wir uns in unserem körper befinden
jetzt würde es wirklich spekulativ aber
das ist vielleicht auch der grund warum
es alles andere als klar ist was mit
solchen gehirn computer interfaces
wirklich bei uns im kopf passiert
vielleicht ist die idee ja nicht so
schlecht da etwas vorsichtig zu sein
können wir unser gehirn hecken doktor
watson mit noch einigen anderen infos
zum neuen link gehirn computer interface
anklicken anschauen und abonnieren
natürlich und zwar doktor watson hammer
kanal bis dann bleibt dran